.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
So, jetzt müssen wir
uns in Schale werfen.
Raffael Wohlgensinger will
die Käseindustrie revolutionieren
und die Welt verbessern.
Perfekt.
Wir produzieren gerade, darum
muss ich schauen, ob wir reinkönnen.
Wir müssen das Team fragen.
Dieses Labor in Berlin
ist seine Käserei der Zukunft.
Cool. Gehen wir nach hinten.
Können wir kurz reinschauen?
Da ist z.B. griechischer Feta,
wenn er gepresst wird,
bevor er dann verpackt
und in Würfel geschnitten wird.
Käse wie wir ihn kennen,
aber ohne Tiere.
Statt Kühe füttert Raffael
Hefepilze oder Bakterien,
die dann die gleichen Milchproteine
produzieren.
Käse aus dem Labor -
das gab's so noch nie
und ist gemäss Wissenschaft
ökologischer als tierischer Käse.
Finanzkräftige Investoren
glauben an den Erfolg der Produkte.
Wollt ihr dann
für ganz Europa produzieren?
Für die ganze Welt.
Ein Betrieb mit 100 Angestellten,
gegründet von meinem Schulkollegen.
Wie ist ihm das gelungen
und wie will er in
diesem umkämpften Markt Fuss fassen?
Was macht dich sicher, dass
das alles mit Produktion usw. klappt?
Ein grosses Urvertrauen,
dass man Probleme lösen kann,
wenn sie kommen.
Ich kenne Raffael Wohlgensinger
seit wir Kinder sind.
Für mich ist er Raffi.
Neun Jahre
gingen wir in dieselbe Klasse.
Im Gymnasium wurden wir Freunde.
Danach studierte er in St. Gallen
Betriebswirtschaft
und hatte diese Idee
des tierfreien Käses.
* Lockere Musik *
# Ooh-ooh-ooh. Ooh-ooh-ooh.
Ich schaue in die Welt und wenn ich
ein Problem sehe, denke ich:
"Das muss ich lösen."
Ich denke oft,
dass ich verantwortlich dafür bin.
So: "Wenn ich es nicht mache,
macht es niemand."
Wenn ich mir die Lebensmittel-
industrie anschaue, denke ich:
"Das ist nicht richtig so."
Das ist nicht nachhaltig.
Ich will nicht,
dass Tiere in diesen Massen
in diesem Lebensmittelsystem
weiterhin ausgenutzt werden.
Ich finde es nicht ethisch,
nicht nachhaltig, nicht gesund.
Ich finde es einfach unwürdig.
Dann denke ich: "Es ist
meine Aufgabe, das zu lösen."
Ich habe es gesehen,
ich habe es verstanden -
also muss ich es
auch irgendwie lösen.
Berlin bietet dem 30-Jährigen alles,
was er für seine Lösung braucht:
kluge Köpfe,
Start-up-Spirit, potente Investoren.
Ich begleite ihn morgens um 8.30 Uhr
in sein Unternehmen.
Es ist nicht viel los.
- Noch nicht, nein.
In Berlin ist um diese Zeit
noch nicht viel los. Moin.
Ist das ein Ding,
dass du immer der Erste sein musst?
Nein, ich muss nicht,
aber ich bin's gerne.
Ah perfekt, danke.
Good morning.
Vorbereitungen für eine Degustation.
Heute kommen potenzielle Investoren
aus Hongkong zu Besuch.
Die aufwändige Forschung im Labor
kostet viel Geld.
Die ersten Produkte sollen Mitte 2024
auf den Markt kommen.
Bis dahin lebt die Firma
vom Glauben an den Erfolg.
Und dieser scheint riesig.
Verschiedene Investoren
haben insgesamt 52 Mio. Euro
ins Unternehmen gesteckt -
Rekord für ein Food-Tech-Start-up
in Europa.
Dieses Jahr hofft CEO Raffi
auf weitere 50 Mio.
Möchtest du sie als Investoren?
- Ja.
Das wäre sehr cool. Wir haben ja
schon einen Investor aus Hongkong.
Das ist ein spannender Markt.
Sie haben supergute Connections
im asiatischen Raum.
Vor fünf Jahren
waren sie die Ersten,
die einen Industriereport
zu "Fermentation in food"
geschrieben haben.
Sie wissen wirklich, worum es geht.
Und es ist cool,
Leute an Bord zu haben,
die nicht nur investieren, sondern
auch die Industrie verstehen.
Schön, euch wiederzusehen.
- Cynthia.
Andere Haare?
- Ja.
Wie geht es euch?
- Good.
Das ist der offene Bürobereich.
Das war immer ein Traum von mir:
ein Büro mit Schlafkabine.
Das hier ist der Spielplatz
für das innere Kind in uns.
An langen und heissen Tagen
füllen wir es auf und baden darin.
Und ...
Wir machen hier
Thinktanks, Panels ...
Wir nutzen es wirklich
als Hotspot für Food-Tech in Berlin.
Wir wollen ein Leuchtturm sein.
Wir können auch noch kurz ins Labor.
Wir arbeiten hier auch
an verschiedenen Arten von Reibkäse
für Pizza,
an unterschiedlichen Zusammen-
setzungen an Fett, Proteinen usw.
Wow!
- Ja.
"Die Zukunft der Molkerei" -
so nennt Raffis Firma Formo
die eigene Mission.
Tierfreier Käse in allen Variationen.
Geschmack, Textur und Nährwerte
sind identisch mit tierischem Käse.
Doch Mikroorganismen arbeiten
effizienter und ökologischer.
Eine Food-Revolution.
Ökonom Raffi und
Molekularbiologin Britta Winterberg
haben das Unternehmen
vor fünf Jahren gegründet.
Mittlerweile ist sie
nicht mehr in der Firma aktiv,
aber nach wie vor Teilinhaberin.
Aus einem Duo wurde im Nu
eine Firma mit fast 100 Angestellten:
Marketingstrategen, Biologinnen,
Lebensmitteltechnologen.
Gut, legen wir los.
Und Raffi hat noch ein weiteres
Produkt im Ärmel: Ei aus dem Labor.
Auch dafür erledigen Mikroorganismen
die Arbeit des Huhns.
Insbesondere für den asiatischen
Markt ist das Ei interessant.
Rührei zuerst.
Wie jedes andere Ei.
- Wie das Rührei heute Morgen.
Das schmeckt gleich.
- Exakt gleich.
Es ist das Protein,
das ihm diese Textur gibt.
Das ist der Frischkäse
namens "Frischhain",
dann "Athena", der griechische,
und der Weissschimmelkäse.
Ihr könnt mit dem Geruch starten.
Sehr mild.
- Ja, supermild.
Können wir ein Foto machen?
- Klar.
Cool. Thank you. Thank you so much.
Thanks. It was lovely meeting you.
Wie ging es mit denen von Hongkong?
- Sehr cool.
Das Feedback war gut.
Sie sind meganett. Ich bin happy.
Schauen wir mal.
Raffis Firma
braucht Investoren für den Betrieb.
Denn solange die Produkte
nicht auf dem Markt sind,
verdient die Firma keinen Cent.
Ein paar Wochen später
treffe ich Raffi wieder da,
wo wir beide aufgewachsen sind
und unsere Eltern immer noch wohnen:
in Hettlingen,
einem Dorf im Zürcher Weinland.
Ich habe gerade vorgestern
nochmals mit meinen Eltern geredet.
Für mich ist es schon krass:
In Hettlingen zu sein,
ist schon noch sehr, sehr Heimat.
Meine Familie ist hier, da vorne
ist mein Tennisklub, die Badi,
der Volg, bei dem ich
mein Leben lang eingekauft habe.
Die Schule ist da oben usw.
Das war ein extrem wichtiger Teil
meines Lebens
und ist es immer noch.
Immer wenn ich hier bin,
kommt mir alles andere
auch ein bisschen unwirklich vor.
Zusammen gehen wir zu Raffis Vater.
Er betreibt ein Sanitärgeschäft.
Ich glaube, er ist noch unterwegs.
Ich war so frech
und habe schon Kaffee rausgelassen.
Das ist gut.
- Willst du auch einen?
Hi, Christoph.
- Tschau. Hoi. Wie geht es?
Sali.
- Hoi. Nein, ist gerade gut.
Ich musste mich gerade wieder
über einen Idioten ärgern.
Sicher. Nein.
Manchmal fragt man sich schon.
Kein Wunder
will niemand mehr auf den Bau.
Jeder wurstelt etwas für sich.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie es in der Käsebranche ist.
Bei uns ist es jedenfalls so.
Nati? Hoi. Ich bin in der Werkstatt.
Mhm. Mhm.
Kenny, hättest du gedacht, dass er
mal ein so grosses Unternehmen hat?
Ein  s o  grosses Unternehmen -
dazu machte ich mir nie Gedanken.
Aber schon, dass er
irgendetwas selbstständig macht.
Du hast es ja vorgelebt.
Ja. A, habe ich es vorgelebt,
und B, lässt er sich
nicht so gerne führen.
Wie ich auch nicht. Sicher.
- Stimmt.
Ich brauche niemanden, der mir
morgens sagt, es sei 7.03 Uhr.
"Pünktlichkeit."
Und wenn du abends länger arbeitest,
interessiert es plötzlich
niemanden mehr.
Ich merke: Zu Hause
kann Raffi ganz er selbst sein.
Hier wird er ausnahmsweise nicht nur
als CEO und Gründer angeschaut.
Und ich erfahre,
dass die letzten Jahre
für ihn selbst
nicht immer einfach waren.
Ja ...
Der Druck wurde enorm.
Gerade vor etwa eineinhalb Jahren -
gefühlt -
warst du ziemlich ...
... stressato.
- Mhm.
Und nachher musstest du
selber sagen: "Hey, normal."
Du kannst ja nur machen,
was du kannst.
Du kannst
nicht alles selber steuern.
Dann wurdest du ruhiger.
Jetzt ist es besser.
Für mich hat sich extrem viel
verändert in meiner inneren Welt.
Du hast es besser im Griff.
- Ich kann mich besser distanzieren.
Ich kann besser sagen:
"Ich kontrolliere, was ich kann."
Alles andere
kann ich nicht kontrollieren,
also muss ich mir
keine Gedanken darüber machen.
Sonst hättest du Sanitärinstallateur
lernen können.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob das weniger Stress gewesen wäre.
Vermutlich schon.
- Nein, ich weiss nicht.
Das wollten wir mal machen.
Wir meinten, es wäre doch cool, wenn
er an den Hochschulabschluss HSG
noch schnell
den Klempner anhängen würde.
Hättest du das gut gefunden?
- Das wäre geil gewesen.
Soll ich das Handy abstellen?
- Du kannst antworten.
Ich antworte noch kurz. Jasmin?
Hoi, hoi. Hör kurz zu:
Ich war in der Badi.
Dort geht es noch darum ...
Kann ich es sagen?
Zurück in Raffis Unternehmen.
Jetzt ist er wieder
in seiner Geschäftsführerrolle.
Moin.
Alles fit, Basti?
- Alles super.
Schön.
Ich will wissen,
wie Raffi als Chef ist.
Hä?
Er ist sehr motivierend,
energetisch.
Er ist so ein Typ, der immer
das grosse Ganze im Blick hat.
Er strahlt so.
Immer begeistert von den Produkten,
die wir ihm zeigen,
selbst wenn wir als
Produkteentwickler skeptisch sind.
Alle reden so gut von ihm.
Es liegt vielleicht
auch am selben Alter. Oder ...
Na ja,
es ist einfach ein guter Vibe.
Es schwärmen alle von dir.
Schön, das freut mich.
Was willst du:
Americano oder Espresso?- Espresso.
Bist du gerne Chef?
Ich finde die Frage
ein bisschen asozial.
Es liegt vielleicht
auch an der Generation,
aber das Wort Chef
ist meganegativ behaftet.
Es wirkt so, als laufe ich rum
und sage den Leuten den ganzen Tag,
was sie zu tun haben.
Ich würde mich eher als einer der
Leader des Unternehmens bezeichnen.
Für mich geht es
um den energetischen Drive,
den jemand ins Team reinbringt.
Weil ich das gestartet habe
und es mir am Herzen liegt,
sehe ich mich
als eine der wichtigen Personen,
die das energetisch vorantreiben.
Ich gebe Energie,
Arbeit, Fleiss und Vision. So.
Und das macht mir sehr Spass.
* Räuspern *
So.
Ein Chef, der keiner sein will.
Jetzt gehen wir
ins Molekularbiologielabor.
Er führt mich dahin, wo am Kern
seiner Produkte getüftelt wird:
den Proteinen.
- Thank you.
Eine Milch
enthält unterschiedliche Proteine.
Und je nach Produkt,
das man herstellen will -
Käse, Joghurt, Glace
oder was auch immer -
spielen unterschiedliche Proteine
mal eine wichtigere und mal
eine weniger wichtige Funktion.
Wir suchen uns in diesen Proteinen
die wichtigsten für uns raus.
Konkret versucht
Raffis wissenschaftliches Team,
die DNA von Mikroorganismen
wie Bakterien oder Hefepilzen
so zu verändern,
dass sie das Gleiche machen
wie sonst Kühe.
Sie sollen naturidentische
Milchproteine herstellen,
aus denen dann Käse gemacht wird.
Ohne Soja, ohne Nüsse.
Gibt es andere Unternehmen,
die das Gleiche machen wie ihr?
Ja, es gibt weltweit
ein paar Unternehmen,
die am Gleichen forschen
und entwickeln.
Wir waren weltweit das zweite,
das zu diesem Thema gearbeitet hat.
In den letzten zwei Jahren gab es
eine Explosion an neuen Start-ups,
die in diesem Bereich arbeiten.
Es sind nicht mehr nur wir,
die sagen,
wir brauchen Mikroorganismen
anstelle von Kühen,
um die bioidentischen Inhaltsstoffe
und Proteine herzustellen.
Werdet ihr die Ersten sein, bei denen
man es essen kann?- In Europa.
Schafft ihr das?- Ich hoffe es.
Wir sind auf einem guten Weg.
Ein Hindernis
gibt es aber noch für Formo:
Aktuell ist das wichtigste Protein
zur Herstellung von Käse, das Kasein,
in der EU noch nicht zugelassen,
wenn es aus dem Labor kommt.
Bis zur Zulassung
dauert es noch mind. zwei Jahre.
Just shooting a bit here.
Bis es so weit ist, ersetzen bereits
zugelassene Proteine das Kasein.
Das ist
der kleine Fermentationsraum.
Hier testen wir die verschiedenen
Bakterien, Hefepilze:
Produzieren sie Proteine? Wie viele?
Unter welchen Konditionen?
Das Zauberwort heisst Fermentation.
Hier drin produzieren die Mikro-
organismen die gewünschten Proteine.
Hier sind die Samples.
So sieht es dann aus.
Das ist ein Beta-Lactoglobulin,
ein Molkeprotein.
Welcher Käse entsteht daraus?
- Das brauchen wir für fast alles.
Aber mit diesem haben wir
Streichkäse gemacht und auch Feta.
Das funktioniert
auch in anderen Produkten gut,
aber mehrheitlich
in frischeren, weissen Käsen.
Hattest du die Idee,
dass das funktionieren könnte?
Obwohl du biologisch eigentlich
keine Ahnung von all dem hattest?
Ja. Also,
am Anfang hatte ich keine Ahnung.
Ich habe mich
schon recht tief eingearbeitet.
Ich habe auch über Monate
verschiedene Onlinekurse gemacht.
Diese ganzen edX-Kurse: Biology 101,
Industrial Biotechnology,
Synthetic Biology ...
Es ist nicht so, dass ich mich
an eine Laborbank setzen
und die Experimente
selber machen kann,
aber zumindest
verstehe ich konzeptionell,
wie es funktionieren sollte
und welche Expertise wir im Team
brauchen, um es umzusetzen.
Ich fahre an die Zürcher Hochschule
für Angewandte Wissenschaften,
ans Institut für Lebensmittel-
und Getränkeinnovation.
Hier beschäftigt sich Professor Tilo
Hühn mit der Ernährung der Zukunft.
Wenn wir uns weiter so verhalten,
essen wir wortwörtlich
diese Welt auf.
Also die belebte Welt.
Und es wird wahrscheinlich
zu Katastrophen kommen,
die wir uns
noch gar nicht vorstellen können.
Und kann man wirklich
dieselben Proteine herstellen,
wie sie in Kuhmilch vorkommen?
Das ist möglich, ja.
- Keine Zweifel?- Keine Zweifel.
Von Professor Hühn will ich wissen,
wie er Raffis Unternehmen einschätzt.
Formo hat insofern
einen ganz starken Stand
und es hat einen Schritt gemacht,
der bedeutend ist.
Sie haben
sehr, sehr viel investiert
und
wissenschaftliche Arbeit geleistet.
Und auch ein Narrativ entwickelt,
das
von den Menschen verstanden wird.
Formo verspricht ja,
viel ökologischer zu sein:
weniger CO2, weniger Wasser,
weniger Landfläche. Stimmt das?
Von der Anlage dieser neuen
Technologie her ist es möglich,
diese Ziele zu erreichen.
Aber man kann das erst bewerten,
wenn eine Anlage mit
entsprechender Produktionskapazität,
die auch Massentauglichkeit
sicherstellt, erstellt ist.
Der Preis werde entscheiden,
ob die Konsumenten
die Produkte von Formo akzeptieren.
Gemäss Unternehmen
werden sie anfangs rund 20 %
teurer sein als tierischer Käse.
* Dynamische Musik *
Hast du dich auch schon gefragt,
warum du das alles machst?- Sicher.
Mein Leitsatz ist ja:
Das eigene Leben vor 9 Uhr morgens
nicht infrage stellen.
Aber es ist halt ...
Es ist sicher ein Kompromiss.
Ich suche mir
in dieser Phase meines Lebens aus,
diese Person zu sein.
Ich bin halt sehr viel unterwegs,
arbeite sehr viel,
habe wenig Zeit
für mein privates Umfeld,
für meine Familie,
für meine Verlobte.
Wieso bleibst du momentan dabei
und machst weiter?
Warum steckst du weiterhin
so viel Energie rein?
Hm!
Ich würde mal sagen:
Schon der tiefe Glaube, dass wir da
einer Sache auf der Spur sind,
die wirklich
einen Unterschied macht.
Auch Raffis Verlobte Rebecca
ging im Gymnasium
in dieselbe Klasse mit uns.
Damals, als 16-Jährige,
wurden die beiden ein Paar.
Wie hast du dich dazu entschieden,
auch nach Berlin zu kommen?
Ich wollte natürlich unbedingt
meinen Master fertig machen.
Und dann war für mich klar:
"Raffi ist hier,
also bin ich auch hier."
Auch Rebecca hat sich in Berlin
als Unternehmerin
selbstständig gemacht.
Davor studierte sie wie Raffi
Wirtschaft in St. Gallen.
Du kennst Raffi ja schon megalange.
- Mhm.
Jetzt kennst du Raffi auch als
Unternehmer. Hat ihn das verändert?
Ich glaube,
was ihn auszeichnet, ist,
dass er die Sachen
aus dem Herzen heraus macht.
Es ist ihm extrem wichtig,
dass viel Integrität dabei ist,
bei dem, was er macht.
Dass es Entscheidungen sind,
mit denen er sich wohlfühlt
und die von Herzen kommen.
Das hat sich nicht verändert.
Ich habe auch das Gefühl,
er war immer ein Leadertyp,
der Leute mitreisst
und ehrgeizig ist.
Ja, voll.
Er ist selbst extrem motiviert
und ich glaube,
das ist ansteckend für viele.
Darum war das bis jetzt
auch so erfolgreich, wie es war.
Weil die richtigen Leute motiviert
werden, um mit ihm mitzuziehen.
War es für dich nie ein Thema,
auch für die Firma zu arbeiten?
Wir haben ganz am Anfang
hin und wieder darüber gesprochen.
Aber so viel in Raffis Leben
dreht sich um diese Firma
und es braucht extrem viel Zeit
und emotionales Involvement.
Wenn ich auch noch
dort arbeiten würde,
gäbe es
keinen Rückzugsort mehr für ihn.
Was gibt es eigentlich?
- Ja, gute Frage. Viel Gemüse.
Das kommt jetzt dann
gleich alles in den Ofen.
Soll ich das schneiden?
- Du kannst das schneiden.
Im Prenzlauer Berg wohnen die beiden
in einer Zwei-Zimmer-Wohnung.
Sie wirkt eher
wie eine Studentenwohnung
als die eines CEOs
eines Millionenunternehmens.
Rebi, er wurde wegen dir ...
Du warst zuerst vegan, oder?
Ich war zuerst vegan, richtig.
Keine Faktenverdrehung.
Nein, nein.
Hast du ihn sozusagen überzeugt?
Ich habe ... Ja, in dem Sinne schon.
Aber ich habe nicht versucht,
ihn ...
Raffi ass sehr gerne Fleisch.
Ich auch.
Ich wusste, dass es nichts bringt,
den Moralapostel zu spielen.
Genau darum hat es funktioniert.
- Genau darum.
Ich fand einfach,
dass ich damit anfange.
Dann ging es wenige Monate
und er zog nach.
Ich würde sagen,
durch mein gutes Vorbild.- Absolut.
Ja.
Was magst du eigentlich an Raffi?
- Oh.- Oh.
Was kann man an Raffi
nicht gerne haben, frage ich.
Nein. Also, ich meine: doch.
Ich habe noch nie ...
Also Raffi ist der herzlichste,
grosszügigste und -
wie sagt man? -
integerste Mensch, den ich kenne.
Ja.
Zurück in der Businesswelt.
Ich begleite Raffi
an eine grosse Food-
und ClimateTech-Messe in Lausanne.
Hey! Raffael.
- Put your name ...- Okay, cool.
Are you a speaker?
- Ich bin ein Referent, ja.
Thanks guys. Jetzt schauen wir mal,
wen wir hier kennen.
Yo. Hey.
- Hey man. How's it going?
Hey.
- Hey, Martin.
Hi!
Alles gut. Privat alles gut,
supertoll mit Rebecca.
Immer noch die gleiche Freundin?
- Verlobte jetzt.
Wow, man. I wanna talk to you ...
Raffi war schon
x-Mal an solchen Events.
Auf mich
wirkt hier alles etwas aufgesetzt.
Eine Welt mit eigenen Codes
und eigener Sprache -
Raffi macht mit.
Was ist dein Ziel hier am Event?
- Gute Frage.
Es ist natürlich eine Art
Präsenz zeigen in dieser Industrie.
Es sind viele Investoren und Partner
da.
Auch um zu schauen, was Neues läuft,
und auszuchecken, was andere machen.
Serendipity: Man weiss nie genau,
was passiert und wofür es gut ist.
Teilweise trifft man einfach gute
Leute, die Teil des Kosmos werden.
Tatsächlich wird er hier für
sein Netzwerken noch belohnt werden.
Wieso hast du den Armeerucksack an?
- Den habe ich immer dabei.
Schon immer.
Der ist immer dabei.
Das ist auch noch ein Stück Heimat.
Daniel.
Musst du noch
deine Präsentation fertig machen?
Ja. Ich bin froh,
dass ich schon angefangen habe.
Ist das normal?
- Ja, das ist normal bei mir.
Leider.
Immer auf den letzten Drücker
bei solchen Sachen.
Typisch Raffi: Die Vorbereitung
erst kurz bevor es ernst gilt.
Das war schon im Gymnasium so.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Hey.
Du siehst, ich bin gleich fertig.
In 5 Min. bin ich da.
- 10 minutes before is fine.
Perfect.
- Okay?
Bitte begrüsst auf der Bühne:
Raffael,
Gründer und CEO von Formo in Berlin.
Nice to have you here.
- Thanks. Hey everybody. Hey.
Gute Neuigkeiten: Wir können tolle
Produkte machen. Hier eine Auswahl.
Ein Zitat eines hoffentlich
zukünftigen Geschäftspartners:
"Wir haben über 200 Tastings
mit tierfreien Produkten gemacht
und nie
hatten wir einen besseren Käse."
Raffi in seinem Element:
als Verkäufer.
Ein überzeugendes Narrativ
scheint mir in diesem Business
besonders entscheidend
für den Erfolg.
Jetzt müssen wir
den Massenmarkt erobern,
um das volle Potenzial zu nutzen.
Let's do a quick photo.
- Sure, let's do it. All of us.
Nach seiner Präsentation wird Raffi
von einem Vertreter von REWE,
Deutschlands zweitgrösster
Supermarktkette, angesprochen.
Ja?
Ich wollte mal ganz kurz
die Gelegenheit nutzen.
Hi. REWE?
- Deswegen ...
Ah.
- Wir wollen mit dir sprechen.
Ja. Geil.
Lass mich kurz mein iPhone holen,
dann connecten wir ganz kurz.
Was war der Nachname? Tischer. Geil.
Lasst uns sprechen. Kommt vorbei.
Viel Erfolg weiterhin.
- Mach's gut. Tschau.
War der von REWE? Was wollte der?
Er hat gesagt: "Wir müssen
unbedingt mal vorbeikommen
und Produkte probieren,
wir wollen die auch haben."
Das wäre ja megageil.
- Ja, ja, total. Total.
Deutschland ist der erste Markt,
den Raffi erobern will.
Ab Sommer 2024
werden Frischkäse, Feta und Rührei
im Detailhandel erhältlich sein.
Nun gilt es, diese
in grossen Mengen zu produzieren.
Ein paar Monate später
reise ich nach Bremen.
Hier befindet sich Formos
erster Produktionspartner:
ein herkömmlicher Käseproduzent.
Heute
testen Raffis Lebensmitteltechnologen
erstmals die Produktion
einer grösseren Menge Frischkäse.
Das ist jetzt Fett, das dazukommt.
Dafür mischen sie das Proteinpulver
aus dem Labor
mit pflanzlichem Fett, Wasser,
Kohlenhydraten und Salz
und verarbeiten die Masse dann
wie bei einem
vergleichbaren tierischen Produkt.
* Erwartungsvolle Musik *
Ein spezieller Moment.
- Genau.
Die erste Produktion.
Zur Produktion des Käses
greift Formo auf das Wissen der
herkömmlichen Käseindustrie zurück.
Der Lebensmitteltechnologe
und Geschäftsführer
des 100-jährigen Traditionsbetriebs,
Jan-Wilhelm Brüns,
hat einen Produktionsvertrag
mit den Berliner Pionieren.
Ich finde es faszinierend,
dass wir die Möglichkeit haben,
an einen anderen Rohstoff zu kommen,
der zwar milchähnlich ist,
aber eben
frei von tierischen Zutaten,
dass wir die Möglichkeit haben,
über mikrobakterielle Fermentation
einen Rohstoff zu erzeugen,
der viele Probleme lösen könnte,
die anstehen.
Wie den Klimawandel
und die Probleme,
ausreichend Protein für die stei-
gende Weltbevölkerung zu erzeugen.
Die Produktion in grösseren Mengen
bringt neue Herausforderungen
mit sich.
Noch schmeckt das Produkt
nicht gleich
wie in der Laborkäserei in Berlin.
Ich finde ihn sehr gut.
Es bleibt noch ein bisschen
Belag auf der Zunge zurück,
was man bei guten, typischen
Milchfrischkäsen nicht so hat.
Und es ist noch ein ganz leichter
Proteingeschmack da.
Aber abgesehen davon finde ich es
sehr gut. Was denkt ihr?
Wir sind bei 70 %.
* Lachen *
Ja, es ist schon ein gutes Produkt,
aber noch nicht zu 100 %
vergleichbar mit echtem Frischkäse.
Die Aufgabe
bis zum Markteintritt im Sommer 2024:
Den Geschmack
auch in grossen Mengen hinzukriegen.
Kurz vor Weihnachten
treffe ich Raffi noch mal
in unserem Heimatdorf Hettlingen.
Du wolltest dieses Jahr nochmals
eine Finanzierungsrunde machen.- Ja.
Unterschreiben werden wir sie
dieses Jahr nicht mehr.
Aber zumindest haben wir Klarheit,
wer sie machen wird
und wer mit reinkommt.
Geplant ist, Ende Januar
oder Februar zum Notar zu gehen.
Wie viel Geld wäre das?
Ich muss kurz schauen.
Ca. noch mal 60 Mio. Euro.
- 60 Mio.?
Also mehr als ihr insgesamt über
die ganze Zeit eingenommen habt?
Ja, vom Volumen
etwa gleich viel wie das,
was wir bis jetzt eingenommen haben.
Ja.
Je mehr Investorenkapital
im Unternehmen ist,
desto kleiner
wird Raffis Anteil daran.
Von anfänglich 60 %
sind es aktuell nur noch etwa 15 %.
Ist es schwierig, dass dir
immer weniger gehört?- Gar nicht.
Warum nicht? Das ist ja dein Baby.
- Ja, voll. Absolut.
Das ist auch immer wieder
eine spannende Diskussion
mit Investoren und Partnern.
Mein wahrgenommenes Gefühl davon,
wie stark das Unternehmen meins ist,
hat sich überhaupt nicht verändert
mit meinem tatsächlichen Anteil,
den ich von der Firma halte.
Es ist gefühlt immer noch voll deins?
- Zu 100 %.
Wirklich?
- Noch wie am ersten Tag, ja.
Mein Schulfreund Raffi:
Ein begnadeter Unternehmer
voller Energie,
der mit seinem verrückten Projekt
eine einmalige Chance nutzen will -
und der dabei für den Erfolg
auch loslassen lernt.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2024